♪ To the rhythm I believe, ♪
♪ It's the power of wings ♪
(radio playing)
- Hey what's up y'all.
- [All] Deuce!
- Hey, what you guys playin'?
- Oh naw, just a
little DVD right?
- What DVD?
- Uh, it came for
you in the mail.
It says, "To my fresh
dope son, from MC mom."
(laughter)
- I can't wait to see it.
- Oh no no, wait.
- [All] No, no.
- If there's one thing
we're gonna do today,
we are playing that DVD, c'mon.
- C'mon man.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh god.
- Did you produce this track?
- [All] No, no, c'mon.
- Yo.
(all scream and laugh)
- The mom jeans.
- Look at the sweater!
- (raps) ♪ I'm the M
to the C to the M-O-M
♪ And when it comes
to mom rappers, ♪
♪ I'm the biggity
best of them. ♪
- Wow.
- Oh my gosh.
- Is she rapping?
- (raps) ♪ Sending out this
rhyme to my homie number one
♪ His name's Carl Stewart,
but to me he's just son ♪
♪ Word up! ♪
- Oh!
- Oh my god.
- Okay, she got the
running man now.
- Can we please turn this off?
- Did he say turn it up?
- Turn up!
- (raps) ♪ You left
some stuff behind
♪ that I can send
ya if you need, ♪
♪ Like your best friend
bear and your magazines ♪
♪ Going through all this stuff,
but it looks pretty risky ♪
♪ You use so much lotion, but
your socks sure are crispy ♪
(men exclaim in disgust)
- Mom!
(men laugh and yell)
- C'mon mom!
- (raps) ♪ I've been cleanin'
with the broom and the vacuum
♪ And found Victoria's secret
issues hiding in your room ♪
♪ Every nook and cranny
there are wads of tissue ♪
♪ I can't even open
this swimsuit issue ♪
(men laugh)
- Man, what is
wrong with you bruh?
- I spilled a soda
on that magazine man.
- (raps) ♪ I'm gettin' your
sheets so nice and clean
♪ Like when you wet your
bed till you were 16 ♪
♪ I overreacted,
sorry I spanked you ♪
♪ Look another crispy sock,
[sniffs], no thank you! ♪
- [All] Oh!
- Why?
- She sniffed you.
- That is wrong.
- How many crispy socks
she gon' find dog?
- (raps) ♪ Crispy socks here,
♪ crispy socks there ♪
♪ Crispy socks with
some mystery hair ♪
- We gotta turn it off
right now c'mon you guys.
- We started it,
we gon' finish it.
(beat changes)
- Oh, oh the beat changed up.
(clears throat)
(raps) ♪ I got the
kitchen and the basement
♪ and the living room ♪
♪ And since your dad met that
bitch, I got his office too ♪
♪ Got my juices goin' ♪
♪ My rhymes flowin' ♪
♪ My rap blowin' showin'
no signs of slowin' ♪
♪ I can feel my skills growing ♪
♪ Took a little
practice to crack this ♪
♪ These lyrical gymnastics,
but now the fact is ♪
♪ Queen B, Imma
be throwin' out ♪
♪ your fuckin'
mattress hell ya ♪
♪ baddest bitch in the biz ♪
♪ Takin' the show on the road, ♪
♪ you can clean up
your own jizz (bleep) ♪
♪ Peace. ♪
(explosion)
- [All] (scream) Oh!
- Yo, yo, yo, MC Mom
- [All] Put the
pussy on the chainwax
(echoed aye)
(radio playing)
- [Keegan] Let's go pretty boy,
you wanna keep yo
hands off my woman.
- Yo woman? I saw her first.
- But don't you
put yo hands on me.
(arguing)
(cheers and applause)
- [Announcer] And now,
the scat stylings
of Rex, the bone daddy, Ronson
and Teddy, 12 combs, Lewis.
(audience cheers and applause)
(jazz music)
(both scatting)
- (scatting)
♪ Your breath
smells like a butt ♪
(scatting continues)
♪ Your whole mouth ♪
♪ Smells like ♪
♪ An open ass ♪
♪ Butt poop poo ♪
- (scatting)
♪ Fat fat ♪
(scatting continues)
♪ Fatty is you ♪
♪ You're a fat fat fat ♪
(scatting continues)
♪ Fi phi fo fump ♪
♪ What do I smell ♪
♪ But some fat ♪
♪ Next to me ♪
♪ That's the man ♪
(scatting)
♪ Fi fee fo fat ah ♪
- (scatting)
♪ Baby penis ♪
♪ Feel free to suck it ♪
♪ You can suck it and
put it in your mouth ♪
- (sings high notes)
♪ Yo face looks
like a ba-all sack ♪
(scatting)
♪ Wrinkle ditty ball sack ♪
- (scatting)
♪ The space between
the butt and balls ♪
(scatting continues)
♪ Your face is a taint ♪
♪ Taint, taint, taint. ♪
- ♪ Take it back ♪
- ♪ No, I won't ♪
- ♪ I never will ♪
- ♪ Take it back ♪
- ♪ No I won't ♪
- [Both] ♪ 'Cause your
a son of a, son of a, ♪
♪ son of a, son of a
bitch, bitch, bitch ♪
♪ son of a, son of a,
son of a, son of a ♪
♪ bitch, bitch, bitch ♪
(audience cheers and applause)
- ♪ You don't need
to fight over me ♪
♪ There's plenty ♪
♪ Of the (scatting) ♪
♪ Vagina ♪
♪ There's plenty for us all ♪
♪ You know what I'm
talking about right ♪
♪ Y'all know what
I'm talking 'bout ♪
(audience cheers and applause)
(radio playing)
(cash register noise)
(ballad music)
♪ There's a light ♪
♪ And it shines within the
darkness of the sands of time ♪
♪ The sands of time ♪
♪ There's a fight ♪
(cash register noise)
♪ But the battle to be
won is the man inside ♪
♪ The man inside ♪
♪ No valley, no ocean
can stop my devotion ♪
♪ Nothing will keep me
from getting to you ♪
♪ Flying high ♪
♪ To the limit, never
wondering how I touch the sky ♪
♪ Touch the sky ♪
♪ Like a dream ♪
♪ You can never tell the lies ♪
♪ From what's
exactly as it seems ♪
♪ In the rhythm, I believe ♪
♪ Is the power of wings ♪
♪ There's a fire ♪
♪ And it burns the deepest
fathoms of the Seven Seas ♪
♪ The Seven Seas ♪
♪ True desire ♪
♪ Let the music in your heart ♪
♪ Give way to the things
that you believe ♪
♪ Anything you can achieve ♪
♪ Flying high ♪
♪ To the limit, never wondering
how I kiss the clouds ♪
♪ Like a dream ♪
♪ You can never tell the lies ♪
♪ From what's
exactly as it seems ♪
♪ In the rhythm, I believe ♪
♪ Is the power of wings ♪
♪ Anything is achievable ♪
♪ Don't let nobody
tear you down ♪
♪ Sexually ♪
♪ Just take flight,
it's believable ♪
♪ If you first learn
to stand your ground ♪
♪ Flying high ♪
♪ To the limit never wondering
how I touch the sky ♪
♪ Like a dream ♪
♪ You can never tell the lies ♪
♪ from what's
exactly as it seems ♪
♪ Within the rhythms I believe ♪
♪ Is the power ♪
♪ Of wings ♪
(radio playing)
(oldies music)
♪ Would you look at the time ♪
- ♪ You should just
stay here tonight ♪
- ♪ I've had too much wine ♪
- ♪ You can leave
at first light ♪
- ♪ It isn't that far ♪
- ♪ Baby just stay
where you are ♪
- ♪ Back to my place ♪
- ♪ You can't escape
from my embrace ♪
- ♪ I really had
a very nice time ♪
- ♪ Let me just
refill that wine ♪
- ♪ But I really need
to just say goodbye ♪
- ♪ I would love
to see you try ♪
- ♪ Please unlock this door ♪
- ♪ It's locked
from the outside ♪
♪ Babe you might tonight ♪
- ♪ I cannot stay tonight ♪
♪ Look i really have to go ♪
- ♪ No you really have to stay ♪
- ♪ Hey no means no ♪
- ♪ That is what they all say ♪
- ♪ Your hurting my arm ♪
- ♪ I won't cause you any harm ♪
- ♪ Let go of me ♪
- ♪ We can make this
hard or just easy ♪
- ♪ A woman always
comes prepared ♪
- ♪ Ooh I'm really scared ♪
- ♪ I said this is
not what i want ♪
- ♪ Why you have
to be such a-- ♪
- ♪ I know self defense ♪
- ♪ I dare you to try it ♪
- ♪ I don't wanna fight ♪
- ♪ Bitch, you
are mine tonight ♪
(punch)
(punching sounds)
(yells)
♪ Please just please go away ♪
- ♪ I thought you
wanted me to stay ♪
- ♪ Well well I just
changed my mind ♪
- ♪ I think I'll just
stay and unwind ♪
- ♪ How did this all switch? ♪
- ♪ Now you are ♪
♪ my ♪
(slaps)
♪ Bitch ♪
- ♪ Please just
be kind tonight ♪
- ♪ Now you are mine ♪
♪ to ♪
♪ Night ♪
(radio playing)
(cheers and applause)
(funky music)
♪ Got a pocket full of funky
with a peppermint twist ♪
♪ She's a cool, shifty mama
blastin' off on the flip ♪
- ♪ Iridescent pork belly
galactic super train ♪
♪ Mama sister playground
with a straw daddy cane ♪
♪ Uh huh ♪
- ♪ Gotta get it up ♪
♪ Gotta get it on ♪
♪ Gotta get it down ♪
♪ Gotta make it strong ♪
- ♪ Got that quick dip crayon
earthquake jet pack on a bun ♪
♪ Locomotive supernova
Spanish Harlem sun ♪
- ♪ Slick crawfish solar blast
with a phosphorescent brain ♪
- [Both] ♪ Who's that
mama squat town? ♪
♪ Deep fried
Detroit soda train ♪
- ♪ Gotta shake it up ♪
♪ Gotta move it in ♪
♪ Gotta put it down ♪
♪ Gotta make it swim ♪
- ♪ Nebulatic comets
sanitation disease ♪
- ♪ Quick play tornado rip
and tickle beef sneeze ♪
- ♪ Ships planets justice
cannons, cables and trees ♪
- ♪ Doctor's office penguin
shillings, railroads and peas ♪
- ♪ I said crippled donkey
Mel Brooks book train ♪
♪ bats on my knees ♪
- ♪ Penicillin trapdoor
laser currency beans ♪
- ♪ He said penicillin
trapdoor laser currency beans ♪
- Hey, what the hell
are we saying, man?
- I got no idea, man.
I'm just hungry and talking
about the galaxy and trains.
I think they buyin' it, though.
(cheers and applause)
(radio plays)
Who you gonna call?
(upbeat music)
(laughs)
Hi.
I'm Ray Parker Junior,
writer and performer
of the Academy Award
nominated hit single,
"Ghostbusters."
From the major motion picture,
"Ghostbusters,"
but that's just one song.
I've written so many other
major motion picture theme songs
and submitted them
throughout the years.
Now,
they're available and together
for one specially
priced compilation.
Songs like,
♪ You're trying to
play the game, ♪
♪ But it's drivin' you insane ♪
♪ Jumanji ♪
♪ Danger in the jungle ♪
♪ There's a lion in my house ♪
♪ C'mon mister computer ♪
♪ Throw me a bone ♪
♪ I said lawnmower man ♪
♪ Get up off of my lawn ♪
♪ When Armageddon is near ♪
♪ You better get outta here ♪
♪ Look like a ♪
♪ Deep impact ♪
♪ I ain't afraid of no 'stroid ♪
♪ Watch out behind you ♪
♪ That's where Imma find you ♪
♪ Pelican brief ♪
♪ It's gettin' legal y'all ♪
These songs have only been heard
by the highest level of
industry decision makers.
But now you can feel like
a Hollywood executive
in your own home.
♪ I see your face-off ♪
♪ Black guy walkin' around ♪
♪ It's a face-off ♪
(chuckles)
♪ That ain't even your face ♪
♪ Passion of the Christ ♪
♪ Get me down off
of this cross ♪
♪ Passion of the Christ ♪
♪ You know, my
daddy is the boss ♪
♪ Disturbia ♪
♪ That's not even a word ♪
♪ Gonna un-nervia ♪
♪ Now there's a
whole lot of kinky ♪
♪ Bet that room is stinky ♪
♪ Fifty shades of gray ♪
(chuckles)
♪ Alright white people ♪
♪ Who's a slave? ♪
♪ I'm not a slave whoa oh ♪
♪ Twelve years a slave ♪
♪ Whoops ♪
(Imitates whip crack)
There's one thing I know is that
persistence makes perfection.
(chuckles)
Sure,
Hollywood missed out,
but that doesn't
mean you have to.
♪ Down in the basement, ♪
♪ What's going on, it's a ♪
♪ Apt pupil ♪
♪ There's a kid and
a Nazi down there ♪
- [Narrator] Order now
to receive your free copy of
Bobby Sings the Twos,
theme songs to sequels
that were never made.
(upbeat music)